demonstrators outside a federal
government building in Mexico City
they're the families of missing persons
and they say they want answers over why
dozens of Case Files have been erased
from the official Government Census on
forced
disappearances activists showed us
dozens of leaked government documents
appearing to show the names of missing
persons that have been removed from the
public
record they want to make it seem as if
there are no forced appearances in
Mexico but that's not the case elas says
her husband Roberto Mel went missing in
2010 she believes his name is among
those that have been erased she and many
others believe Mexican authorities have
tampered with official records to make
it appear as though hundreds possibly
thousands of missing persons have
already been
found that's why I'm here demanding that
the president tells us where all these
people are that have supposedly been
found
because my husband never returned for
his part president Andres Manuel Lopez
obor has denied the
accusations we have no intention nor
have we ever had the intention of
erasing any disappeared person what
we've conducted is a revision and a
general National search to clarify
precisely what we have in terms of
disappeared and get everything in
order according to the Mexican
government's own records there are been
more than 45,000 cases of missing
persons in Mexico during the Lopez obor
Administration with less than a year
left before the end of President Lopez
obor's term critics say his
administration is trying to manipulate
government statistics ahead of the
upcoming national
election information regarding the
methodology used to update the National
Registry on missing persons has not been
made publicly available families of
missing persons in Mexico say it's a way
for the government to make their loved
ones disappear for a second time Manuel
rapo Al jazer Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer